à la lettre b dans le petit larousse on
trouve donc désormais aux côtés de
bacchus dieu du vin paul bocuse dieu de
la cuisine si dans la mythologie romaine
la date de naissance de bacchus est
incertaine
le petit larousse nous apprend que paul
bocuse est né à collonges-au-mont-d'or
en 1926 et qu'il est un des rénovateurs
de la cuisine française mondialement
connu en fait avec baucus et la cuisine
française qui entre dans le larousse
puisque à ses côtés on trouve alain
chapel et les frères troisgros et bien
ça me fait très plaisir d'ailleurs c'est
vous qui me l'avait amené là maintenant
et je vois que je suis prêt de bocage et
bocage on m'a toujours dit que nous ne
beaucoup venaient de blocage
donc je trouve ça formidable mais aussi
que bocage et dans les noms propres et
noms communs alors j'ai regardé ces
éléments communs je suis encore pas dans
les noms communs je pense ce grand
succès c'est quand je serai dans les
noms propres dans les noms communs
je voyais à boileau boileau bon ben
c'est bien beau lot mais je m étais
peut-être mieux bolvin pour mon métier
il y a
bokassa bon bah c'est un empereur il y a
un peu plus loin
bacchus qui peut se rapprocher à bocuse
il y a pourquoi on va bacchus je crois
que lui c'était le dieu du vin et puis
moi tout simplement le petit seigneur de
ma soupe